heard versus death the exes taking their
bitter battle back to court the judge
did what the judge said she was going to
do she rendered a judgment on the
verdict et's exclusive sit down with
bree tiacy who's expecting nick cannon's
eighth child her birth plan and how he
splits time with five different women we
all can go through the assistant to make
sure it's on the calendar thor love and
thunder bring in the booty in high
definition full booty go see it on imax
it's even bigger plus the battle of the
hemsworth brothers
and luke hemsworth is the funniest one
yes maybe it's like whichever hemsworth
i happen to be
at the premiere of something with i
should say is the funniest hemsworth the
download starts right now
the battle of the x's isn't over just
yet johnny depp and amber heard's
lawyers were back in court today to see
if the parties could settle before the
court officially entered a final
judgment on the defamation verdict
reached three weeks ago and it's
official the judge ruled that amber is
on the hook for more than 10 million
dollars and that's not all if she
appeals what she has vowed to do she'll
be required to pay six percent interest
which is more than half a million
dollars
amber heard lawyers had indicated before
uh today's hearing that amber heard
could not afford to pay the judgment
many people are guessing that there's
going to be donors that are there to
support her another unexpected ruling
today the judge did not allow an
injunction from johnny's team to hold
amber accountable for continued claims
of abuse which she's doubled down on in
interviews since the verdict to my dying
day will stand by every word of my
testimony this was the most humiliating
and horrible thing i've ever been
through and she's reportedly in talks to
write a multi-million dollar revenge
book a source tells e.t she has plans to
make a comeback over the next year
neither depp nor heard were in court
today and depp's superstar lawyer
camille vasquez wasn't either but she
was recently spotted in new york and on
a cross-country flight this week where
she reportedly rushed to the aid of an
elderly man who collapsed on her flight
eyewitnesses for tmz say the crew called
her wonder woman and thanked her with a
bottle of champagne
now on to a new beginning for nick
cannon and bree tiazi she's due any day
now with nick's eighth child and in part
two of kevin frazier's at-home exclusive
brie answers the big question
how in the world does the busy dad keep
up with all them babies
how do you split time or how will nick
you know how often will he be able to
come see his son i mean that all
obviously dictates what's going on in
his work schedule um we all can go
through the assistant to make sure it's
on the calendar if there's something
important um
but anything you say you need from him
this man always shows up so tell me
about the delivery will nick be here yes
nick will absolutely be here he has no
choice
but i'm actually having it at the house
i'm gonna have our son here and just i'm
doing it on medicated as well so bravely
we'll see we'll see if i regret this
at first nick wasn't fully on board with
the home birth especially since losing
his five-month-old son zen last december
from brain cancer he is a little
concerned especially you know he has a
sensitive after a loss is a little bit
more sensitive now
so i wanted to respect that but i also
was like i'm the one birthing him so he
was like i'll support you and if
anything we go to the hospital
do you have a name i do i had come up
with one name and he jazzed it up a
little bit
it's not like
too
out there
so it'll be a little bit different i
feel like one day there could be a show
called the canons or something like that
could there maybe would you do reality
tv i yeah i would i don't know if i
would go necessarily housewife vibe but
i ended up getting a really amazing
opportunity which i can't share just yet
for now bree and nick's beautiful
nursery is all ready to welcome their
baby boy alex cash helped me do this
entire design and when i saw it i fell
in love with it
look at these amazing knitted jordans so
cute we're going to dress them up and
i can't wait people seem to be very
opinionated about your relationship and
they're like how is she doing it why is
she doing this he's got too many
children yeah for me i really just kind
of it doesn't actually genuinely affect
me they're used to their conventional
relationships that's what we're taught
that's what's instilled in us
um but stuff like whatever you want to
call this has been going on forever
you know kelly clarkson's also no
stranger to relationship drama either
and there is a big development in her
divorce settlement her ex-husband
brandon blackstock has reportedly moved
out of kelly's montana ranch and into
this 1.8 million dollar montana home now
kelly tried to have brandon evicted a
year ago but a judge gave him until june
1st as long as he paid kelly 12 000 a
month in rent but get this kelly was
ordered to pay him 115 000 each month in
spousal support and more than 45 000 a
month in child support kelly told et how
she's dealing with the split
i don't know how anybody i'll just be
real with you goes through
grief like divorce without having an
outlet like it has i have written like
60 songs
on to bas allurman's elvis which hits
theaters today only et's nichelle turner
met up with the cast in the king's home
in graceland and got austin butler's
take on his newfound fandom
just like elvis you're no stranger to
fame have you had a fan encounter that
you're like whoa i can't believe that
just happened to me i i still have that
feeling of
shock when people know who i am
i mean we had a moment on the plane
where i was like in a mask and a hat
right and the stewardess started playing
uh elvis songs and she said she said
this isn't tribute to you
austin dyed his hair black and wore more
than 90 elvis costumes for the film and
playing the role of then wife priscilla
newcomer olivia deyoung we did so many
hair makeup tests baby that be happening
that thing was we called her the double
decker and i loved her i loved to hate
her because she was so heavy
but god she was glorious so hair and
makeup took like three and a half hours
i've never met anyone like you
i hope not
elvis explores the king's many
relationships told through the eyes of
his manager colonel parker director baz
lerman tells us tom hanks was his first
choice for the colonel i was with him 10
minutes and at the end of 10 minutes he
said well if you want me i'm your guy
wow i wanted the audience to see him do
something
that he'd never done before
without me there would be no
and let's introduce you to some of the
rest of this cast alton mason is little
richard singer yola stars as r b singer
sister rosetta tharp and kelvin harrison
jr plays blues legend bb king bibi was a
big supporter of elvis and he understood
the power and influence that he had and
ultimately that brought more customers
to beale street you don't have elvis
without black music
and culture it was sewn into the fiber
of his being from such a young age
[Music]
it may have taken tom hanks just 10
minutes to land his role in the biopic
but austin butler says his audition
process lasted five months his grueling
road to becoming the king tops tonight's
talk show circuit on the kelly clarkson
show austin said director baslerman put
him through the ringer in a final screen
test that's changed everything on me on
the day and so suddenly i'm on set and
and i go past i don't think i have the
material that you gave me and goes oh no
we changed it but i'll get you i'll get
you new material
and then turns out you never got me a
new material is he just like messing
with you at this point like
i realized i would look around for
ashton kutcher at this point
oh that's rough it was not a prank it
turns out baz just likes to be
spontaneous on set and austin thought he
didn't get the part until one call from
the director changed his life forever
he's very dramatic in the way that he
goes about things and so he was he sound
kind of downcast and he goes oh how mean
i just wanted to be the first one to
call you and say
are you ready to fly mr president
well austin must have been speechless
right just like social media sensation
emma chamberlain after her adorably
awkward interaction with rapper jack
harlow at the met gala in may i'll see
you in there can't wait love you bye
love ya
so cringe but so cute jack dished on the
exchange with jimmy fallon back in may
and now emma is reacting to his reaction
to her reaction that's like a piece of
art because there's so many ways to
interpret that you know what i mean
but do you leave every interview saying
love you
only if i love them
that's sweet that's not bad right i like
that guy i love it when i'm doing these
interviews it's blank up here like i
have no thoughts
huh do we see sparks flying between
these two maybe i mean maybe i don't
know i'd have the same reaction if
somebody they told me they loved me
literally but he's also jack harlow so i
just feel like thank you so much well
however both stars are booked and busy
emma just returned to youtube after a
six-month hiatus and jack is set to make
his acting debut in the white man can't
jump reboot but jack did tell e.t last
month that he's single and ready to
mingle there's always a new crush
is someone here though that you got your
eye on
let me see
i'm right here jack back off my man cass
all right meanwhile we've got our eyes
on jennifer hudson the newly minted egot
winner is taking over daytime and we are
getting our first look at her new talk
show on the jim hudson show you're going
to get quality you're going to get
honesty you're going to get all of my
heart and don't forget the fun we're
going to have a lot of fun the jennifer
hudson show debuts on daytime on
september 12th and we can't say we
didn't see this coming she shared some
scoop with e.t back in january
that would be a whole new interesting
world to walk into i do love talking as
you could probably already tell and see
and i love to jennifer eyes people
jennifer ice people i like those
trademarks another woman of many talents
evan rachel wood the westworld star
revealed a spot-on impression of madonna
on the tonight show
evan is starring as the queen of pop in
the upcoming weird l biopic but says she
didn't actually sing in the role which
as we are learning now might have been a
missed opportunity yeah you can see more
of evan this sunday when westworld
season 4 premieres on hbo this time
around she's playing a newish character
but with potentially the same love
interest
this is a story about a girl james
marsden is back is he teddy who is he is
he good is he bad then tell me more i
know it's like ross and rachel you just
are like waiting so desperately for them
to make it in their happy ending as for
rachel and james's westworld co-star
aaron paul he's on daddy duty at home
and recently showed off his special
skill i have a four four and a half year
old daughter and she was born with a lot
of hair and so i kind of started
learning how to braid pretty early on i
love correcting people when they say oh
my god your mom did such a great job
on your hair and my daughter goes no my
daddy did it just makes me so proud
how was it the second time around he's
three months old and he's just
the sweetest most gentle
kid i love him to death
tessa thompson and luke hemsworth are
also back and tessa is having trouble
picking her favorite hemsworth tess has
had the opportunity now to work with
both you and your brother chris oh yeah
so who would have to say is the funnier
brother come on
definitely not chris he's not like
liquid spend time with all of them
and luke hemsworth is the funniest one
yes but i don't compare they're all
beautiful hemsworthians like you need
them you need them all
when are we going to complete the
trilogy and have you work with liam
maybe when i complete the trifecta i'll
just like vanish into air like i don't
know well who knows i'm kind of scared i
want to liam i think he's a brilliant
actor i just don't know what will happen
to me
[Music]
now if you're wondering what chris
thinks about tessa saying his big bro is
the funny hemsworth you're in luck our
very own cassie delora found out at the
world premiere of thor love and thunder
we talked to tessa thompson earlier this
week and she said that luke was the
funniest hemsworth brother what do you
have to say about that i'd agree i'd
agree the truth is they're all very
funny so
maybe it's like whichever hemsworth i
happen to be
at the premiere of something with i
should say is the funniest hemsworth so
tonight it's chris and liam when you and
i finally do something together it'll be
you it'll be you
luke showed up to support his west world
co-star and is not so little brother
which might get awkward considering
chris totally drops trial in the fourth
thor movie in theaters july 8.
did you have to do extra squats or
anything like that
there's a lot of work yeah i mean it was
kind of
10 11 years into making that shot each
each film we've taken off another item
of clothing and now we just kind of took
it all off is the booty blurred like the
trailer
you get full booty in the movie and go
see it on imax it's even bigger
i saw it last night i can confirm yeah
he should rename his butt cheeks love
and thunder yes i'm here for it glorious
i love it i love it all right now on to
taraji p henson she's returning to host
sunday's p-e-t awards heart pivot right
well the actors told me what to expect
the b-e-t awards is culture's biggest
night y'all i think we counted 10 outfit
changes last year how many do you plan
this year i think 15 or 14 or something
like that very saturday night live
dojicat leads the way with six
nominations performers include babyface
and jack harlow this lifestyle don't got
many downsides is there anyone you're
personally excited to see well i always
love lizzo i hope she brings her flutes
i hope she brings all the thick thighs
hips and ass i want all of it
lizzo will be in the front row alongside
chancellor rapper and diddy who's
receiving the lifetime achievement award
what y'all wanna do wanna be ballers
he's because of a lot of paradigm shifts
in music and in culture and it's time
that we want to give him his flowers
this year and y'all don't want to miss
the performance we have mary j blige we
have little kim we have nas he makes the
phone calls and they come aside from
hosting the bet awards taraji is also
hard at work shooting the color purple's
musical film you certainly aren't
prepared to hear me sing the way i'm
singing in this because i literally
every time i hear myself i'm shocked
over and over again like that's me now
was oprah on set the day you were
filming by chance or when you were
saying absolutely oprah has visited us
twice since i've been filming it's
really about how
miraculously black people can find joy
even in the darkest places
et's kevin frazier will be exclusively
backstage at the bet awards and tonight
he and nichelle turner are hosting the
daytime emmy awards on cbs starting at
9pm eastern with presenters including
drew barrymore the hosts of the talk and
a performance by michael bolt all right
moving on to the shake up as so you
think you can dance matthew morrison's
replacement leah remini is fitting right
in but jojo siwa told us she had her own
replacement in mind
i genuinely did not know it was coming
and i found out when the world found out
i pitched allison hulker twitch's wife
because i was like if he's so cute if it
was like twitch me allison i was like
that'd be such a squad i wanted to
suggest to the producers so bad abby lee
but then i was like i don't think they
think it was a good have you spoken to
matthew
yeah there's cooler things to talk about
matthew's out and leah remini is in but
it was jojo who took a hit when an
online troll reacted to the news of the
glee teachers firing by saying i saw the
headline judge leaves so you think you
can dance and got all excited yes jojo
siwa was out but no now jojo is clapping
back you cannot tell me anything that i
haven't already told myself hate on me
please i'm down
forgot about my dance knowledge like
let's go in fact jojo goes is the name
of the 19 year old's new facebook watch
show out now she tries out a bunch of
dream jobs and we joined jojo
exclusively for her day as an honorary
dodgers employee i'm literally gonna be
working in the stadium getting the
stands ready getting the field ready i
should see if i could steal the players
jerseys and rhinestone them
it is pride night
[Music]
while jojo has been busy on so you think
he can dance world of dance judge neo
has been busy making new music find out
how his near divorce inspired his new
album plus what in the white chicks is
happening here running bands up running
bands up running bands up running
off you can't stand us
the possible connection to tiger's past
playing out in his new music video when
et's the download returns
[Music]
that actress hilary duck's husband
matthew koma just pulled off one epic
prank the 35 year old musician took to
instagram revealing his master plan
saying added the jonas brothers to all
our family photos to see if the wife
notices
[Music]
oh and hillary noticed saying nothing
surprises me anymore and so did the joe
bros kevin entered the chat with three
skull emojis and joe whose face was
pasted over photos of their children
said i love you papa
this man right here has been turning out
hits since his debut in 2005 and now neo
is back with his first full-length album
since 2018 how about that man i'm i'm so
happy yeah it's finally coming out i've
been living with some of these records
for quite some time and you know i i
understand that it's still new to
everybody else but i'm like ah can you
just get it out please so i can start
some other things i bet yeah i'm excited
about it and we need some good tunes
right now you know we need the vibe
you're about to bring it i feel like i
got this okay
[Music]
well let's talk about your song don't
love me which came out a couple months
ago uh you know it's the storytelling
for me you know i don't know if you read
youtube comments do you i do okay yeah
because i was and everyone was just i
this song really resonated with a lot of
people as an artist how does that feel
to take you know something that you're
going on in your own life and sharing it
with the world and people can relate to
that um well i mean that's that's kind
of what the music thing is for you know
um i have uh i've kind of made a career
out of taking
i guess negative situations the black
white and gray of love if you will and
turning it into song form and making
that you know kind of the soundtrack for
people to to live their lives to or you
know to break up to to get back together
to whatever the case may be yeah and it
feels good it feels good to know that
that for one it feels good to know that
you don't go through these things by
yourself you know what i'm saying uh uh
just again the black and white black
white and gray of what love is everybody
kind of goes through similar things and
and you know to have a song that kind of
relates and resonates with what's going
on with you it it softens the blow a
little bit absolutely yeah and that's
what people were saying the comps are
like it's like you're speaking to my
soul it's like it's almost like i wrote
this song you know and you did capture
that black white and gray of love in the
video too i mean tyler lepley and saraya
are in it yeah how amazing was it to get
them to i don't know kind of bring this
story to life um you know what so two
very talented actors and i my heart goes
out thank y'all so much for even doing
the video i genuinely appreciate it um
i just wanted to make sure that that the
story was being told the right way yeah
you know so shout out to the director
shout out to the two of them for just
bringing my vision to life was amazing
beautiful beautiful you know the song is
an open letter to your wife crystal uh
that was written during the pandemic uh
what was her reaction when she first
heard it uh when she first heard the
song yeah um it reminded her of the time
that we were in when i wrote the song
and you know that that was that was that
rough that was a terry moment yeah i
mean because it was written uh the song
was written kind of in the throes of us
going through potentially getting
divorced right you know and and i can
say this now i didn't realize it at the
moment but i can say now that the open
letter was me trying to cop out it was
it was me trying to tell her that i
couldn't be who she deserved in
actuality the reality of it is
it's not that we can't it's that we
won't or that we don't you know what i
mean and if that's the case then then
you're not supposed to be in a
relationship so once i realized what i
wanted and who i needed to be for her
we're in a great place i was gonna say a
real great place i mean come on oh you
guys came out the other side stronger
indeed we renewed our vows in vegas not
too long ago we were real real big with
it way bigger than we should have that's
a lot of money
but it was worth it but it was
definitely worth it everybody had an
amazing time she looked amazing as you
can see and i really wanna see you happy
[Music]
so what advice do you have for couples
kind of experiencing similar struggles
oh man um you know what i'll say above
anything
don't lie to yourself like know what it
is you want to know what it is you want
to do if you are in a relationship and
you don't want to be in a relationship
you're never going to give your all to
that relationship
let's talk about a new bop actually a
new song called you got the body um you
got the body is i won't say it's
different for me but it's it's just
slightly it's slightly sexier than i
than i intended than i tend to go and
that's on purpose you know what i mean
it's one of those records where as soon
as i heard the track i was like okay
yeah this is it's about to be one of
those ones yeah you know so i just i
just took a took a subject matter that
made sense to me uh uh i like to call
the song a um what's the word i call
what's the word it's it's it's a
negotiation piece okay a negotiation
tool if you want negotiation yeah what
do you want fans to know about this next
era of neo um
you know what to be completely honest
with you man i i am just thankful that
that people still give a damn about
about about neo about quality music you
know what i mean
i still got you know i still got a wife
to take care of and children to raise
and and that's still going to happen but
uh but it's win-win it's definitely a
win-win yeah i appreciate my fans i
again i've been here almost 20 years man
wow that's that's that is not a small
feat and we get to see you present at
the bet awards this weekend right yes
yes i be prepared eat i'm always
prepared i always prefer you stay ready
seeing you got to get ready that's right
well congratulations i can't wait for
self-explanatory out july february 15th
man
appreciate your love brother thank you
spin it cause i'm up
running bands up running
[Music]
some more new music has got folks
talking that's tyga and yg as the
calabasas sisters in their new video
will run the calabasas sisters some fans
think they look like the characters from
the 2004 classic white chicks while
others think it's a kardashian's parody
especially considering tyga used to date
kylie either way it makes you want to
dance it makes me do a double take like
that's tyga i know right i love it
i'll watch that that part well that's
gonna do it for us today though tiger
and yg are going to play us out have a
great weekend
bands up guys bands
up running